[Music]
last spring President Trump was widely
ridiculed actually dismissed as a
lunatic for tweeting out that the Obama
administration had wiretapped had
surveilled his campaign before the 2016
election this was all denounced as an
absurd lie a delusion but maybe it
wasn't actually a four-page memo
currently circulating through the
Congress reportedly details pre-election
abuses of FISA that's the law that
allows the executive branch to engage in
the surveillance of American citizens
and was just reauthorized mindlessly by
the Congress that very little fanfare
several Republicans are demanding the
memo be released they're being joined in
that by the ACLU believe it or not
congressman Matt Gaetz represents
Florida he has seen the memo he joins us
tonight Carson thanks coming up so good
to be on Tucker apparently you are bound
by law not to divulge the details of the
memo but give us a sense of your
reaction to it and the extent you can
tell us why it's a big deal what sure I
can tell you that within the last two
hours 63 of my Republican colleagues
joined me in sending a letter to
intelligence chairman Devin Nunez to
immediately hold a vote of the
Intelligence Committee to release this
memo I believe that once the American
people have the opportunity to evaluate
the allegations and claims in this memo
it will become evident the activities of
the last administration the crimes that
I believe were committed and the total
sham that the smaller investigation is
built on a false premise and rotten to
the core Tucker so the president United
States tweeted some months ago and as we
said was widely derided for it that he
believed he was surveilled his staff was
surveilled during the campaign will this
memo bolster that point well talked
about to respond to that question
could potentially confirm or deny the
specifics within that memo and I'm duty
bound not to do that I can't even talk
on television tonight about things that
we've discussed in the past but what I
can say is that this memo names names it
actually connects the players the
entities that folks are very familiar
with names we've heard in the news and
organizations were well aware of it's
also noteworthy that every single
Democrat on the Intelligence Committee
voted against even allowing me to be
able to see the memo or other members of
Congress and though the Republicans
overrode that vote with a majority even
today Democrats are protesting by
refusing to even go to the Intelligence
Committee room and avail themselves to
the information that is in this memo so
I want to blow past the bureaucracy in
the red tape I think the best
disinfectant to the corruption that is
highlighted in this memo will be the
sunshine of transparency and I have
every confidence that speaker Ryan as an
institutionalist will support our
efforts very quickly if we could just
savor the irony you believe that
information in this memo points up
illegal activity by officials in the US
government but it is somehow illegal for
you to say what it is well until we're
able to alter the current classification
right now this is a top-secret document
and so yes that is ironic but I think
heads are gonna roll people are gonna be
fired and there may be some that go to
jail yeah some of us would even expect
that top secret some times it is
designed for self-preservation
maybe that's obvious congressman thank
you for fighting the good fight and I
hope you get this out there in the
public or deserves to be thank you
talker